I don't have to tell you that devices
these days play a central role in our
lives kids get them on average when
they're 12 or 13 at least in this
country and forever after that device is
with them they consulted hundreds of
times a day etc and don't wanna leave
home without it or even sleep with it
but device is negatively affect our
physical mental and social well-being we
will have about 2.5 billion phones on
earth in use this year meaning almost
1/3 of the population and it's pretty
scary actually that we are doing this
experiment without realizing what the
impact Ambati is on people's well-being
basically so only recently in the last
couple of years people have started
studying the effects of cell phone use
on all sorts of things and unfortunately
the news is not very good so we're sort
of the researchers are catching up but
it's basically too late because 2.5
billion people are addicted and glued to
these devices already their studies
showing for example the effects on
posture and back and neck problems with
extended phone use yep impact on
respiration it reduces your lung volume
and your ability to breathe if you use
your phone a lot there's lots of studies
about the effects of sleep 50% of phone
users use their phone at least once in
the middle of the night can you imagine
and there's all these research studies
now that are showing that if you use
your phone before you go to sleep as
well as sort of the amount of time that
you spend on your phone each day
negatively correlates with quality and
duration of sleep and quality and
duration of sleep our direct are
basically risk factors or poor quality
and duration of sleep our risk factors
for heart disease for diabetes for mood
and depression disorders and more
studies are showing the effects other
effects on mental well-being for example
anxiety this is a study that was done in
Britain about young people showing that
number of hours spent on a on a phone
basically is directly correlated or
inversely correlated with mental health
and is correlated with anxiety increased
anxiety that's a people like Betsy
Sparrow at Columbia University are doing
Studies on the effect that these systems
have on our memory and she has shown
that when people for example reads an
article on a computer or a cell phone
versus on paper they actually without
realizing it read completely differently
and they don't internalize what they are
reading they read it much quicker and
just try to get a sense of what's in the
article as opposed to really trying to
let it think in what they are reading
about so they just pick up meta
information about the article because
they realize they can later go back to
the article if they want to look up some
details people who use the Internet to
solve a problem are then increasingly
actually tend to then use the Internet
in the future to solve problems so for
example instead of being creative or
really using your brain to
of a problem or come up with an idea we
much more quickly Google something so if
I tell someone will think of a head hats
described a hat to me people instead of
using their own mind to come up with an
original idea for a hat may actually
Google Images for a hat and the more
they do that the more likely they are to
keep doing that so it really affects our
creativity as well effects on social
interactions it used to be the case that
if you had a problem you would actually
go talk to a friend or call a friend or
call a family member to figure out how
to whatever make spaghetti bolognaise or
whatever it is but now of course we
consult the Internet so it affects our
social relationships as well thank you
and face-to-face interaction so people
have done studies showing that if you
get together for coffee or whatever with
a colleague and you have your phones
there it negatively affects you the
face-to-face interactions even if you
don't even consult the film effects on
attention and task performance just
having a phone upside down on your desk
or workspace somewhere negatively
effects how yeah I see it right there
Michael probably you're probably paying
less attention to what I'm saying
just because your phone is within your
visual field so even without using it
without a phone ever bothering buzzing
people do less well on tasks when there
is a phone somewhere present in their
visual fields it's really scary
basically so I would argue that even
though these devices are sort of sold to
us as increasing our ability to be
successful and learn and perform better
etcetera it's true they put the world's
information at our fingertips but they
actually have a detrimental effect on
things like
mention grits memory emotional
regulation self-confidence creativity
and so on and if you read about what
sort of the important things are that
kids young kids and young adults and so
on should learn the qualities that they
should develop to do well in the 21st
century it is exactly these types of
things the things that actually phones
make us less good at so one reason that
is the case of course is the current
form factor and Albert Smith came up
with his analogy he says basically that
today's smartphone is like a monocle
we've moved away from monocles because
if you use a monocle to be able to see
something better first of all you have
to remember which pocket you put it in
and you have to get it out put it in and
so on before you can use it they they
probably weren't personalized to a
person specific eyesight problems and so
on well today's smartphones are like
that just using it at all even for a
simple task it's an entire disruption of
what it is that you're doing because you
have to find where it is and unlock it
and start an app and so on so it's a
complete disruption of your attention
and so we are trying to I think what we
need is something that is a little bit
more like contact lens as something that
is sort of less that still helps you in
some way but it's less disruptive and
really sort of can change your
perception of reality without you having
to think about using it so we call this
area cognitive augmentation and in my
lab at MIT we try to think of both the
form factors as well as sort of the
style in which you you would use
personal devices that are always with
you but that are less of a distraction
that are really sort of an augmentation
and just like lenses make you see better
they help you sort of with all sorts of
cognitive tasks without you almost being
aware of it
so these cognitive augmentation systems
in contrast with today's interfaces are
always on you don't turn them on or off
they're always on and they're always
aware of the users context and state as
you know that we have a lot more sensors
available these days and so computers
and we can make sense of all this sensor
data so computers can be made much more
aware of what it is that we're doing the
fact that you're right now listening to
a talk for example that there's many
people around you and so on that you are
paying attention or maybe not paying
attention and so on computers have the
ability to know all of that and take
that into account in how they help us
the systems we built the instead of sort
of being a separate device that you use
to consult something or to look up some
information they actually are more a
system that mediates your experience of
reality and changes your experience of
reality and they do that using multiple
modalities not just vision not just
audio but even things like sense and so
on and often conscious as well as
subconscious stimuli
today's interfaces computers and
smartphones only use sort of outputs
that we that require that we pay
deliberate attention to them that we
consciously pay attention to them and
there's a huge opportunity for devices
to actually influence our thinking and
influence our behavior in ways that we
are not even aware of with stimuli that
we notice but that don't sort of
distract us or that we don't consciously
think of
so I think that the time is right for
sort of these cognitive augmentation
systems to be built for one because
first enabler is sort of there we have
lots of different systems now for
sensory augmentation for changing a
person's perception of the world around
them of course visual augmented reality
is sort of really becoming available
with things like magic leap and the
views explained and also and hololens
and so on and they're gradually getting
better and better but there's also
interesting systems in the audio space
for example Bose has this great product
that takes real-time audio and can
totally transform it so that you hear
better or you hear sort of noise and
sound
from a particular direction and all the
sound coming from other directions is
sort of the volume of that is turned
down so they in real-time basically
change the audio so that the audio can
be tuned to whatever it is that you want
to pay attention to there's other types
of interfaces that can change your
perception of sense the reality of sense
and I'll talk about those in a minute a
second enabler that is making these
cognitive augmentation systems possible
is fencing and perception we now have
things like Google clips or other types
of cameras that basically constantly can
be looking at your environment and then
with algorithms like Yolo and so on be
interpreting what it is that is in front
of you and around you and even which
people you're interacting with etcetera
there's systems that can sort of sense
the internal state of the user with for
example that impaired
teeka a bracelet that gives you heart
rate and electrodermal activity which is
sort of a measure of your excitement
level positive and negative there's
things like the muse which now comes in
a very simple glasses form factor this
system can tell you whether you're
focused or not at any point in time and
other data and all of this data can be
interpreted to basically make sense of
the users current state and then decide
how a system can help the user the third
enabler is of course artificial
intelligence we now have good enough
algorithms mostly sort of the neural
Nets of the neural net variety to make
sense of all this data about the user in
the users context and to decide how to
affect the user in real-time in a
particular way so I'll give you some
examples in a minute of how these
cognitive augmentation types of devices
will completely change the way people
make decisions the way people learn the
way we memorize things the way we
regulate our emotions and deal with our
sort of well being and so on so take
decision-making a couple of years ago we
did this system that illustrates this
vision of sort of integrating or
changing a person's perception of
reality and really integrating the
digital world relevant information about
the digital world with a person's
physical surroundings and instead of
with heads up augmented reality display
we used a projected display a projected
system that can pay attention to
anything that you are doing with your
hands or that is in front of you and
cannot meant it with relevant
information so the digital and the
physical war
world's become merged you see the Amazon
rating of a book when you pick up that
book and the reviews that that book got
when you open it up etc so you don't
have to do anything special like get
your phone out to look up the amazon
rating of a book that you see lying
around that seems interesting all of
that sort of automatically is provided
by the system based on the fact that in
1943 Churchill gave a famous target
Harvard University that you are
currently picking up that book so you
don't you don't have to do anything
everything just happens proactively
learning so this this will affect
decision making of course man we can see
all this information about the things
around us projected onto things that we
interact with it will also change
learning and I'm going to dive a little
bit deeper into some of the experiments
that we're doing there we're using the
hololens and other mixed reality
platforms to change the way people learn
a second language so this system word
sense is built by one of my students
it's basically a application on the
hololens that recognizes any objects
around you desk please give me a cup of
milk etc and when it recognizes an
object you can look up all these
definitions or you
overdrinking yes you can hear how the
word word is pronounced etc you can even
get movie's famous movie clips where
that particular object was used to get
an example of how that word is used in a
sentence it's a little bit hard to see
lights because have one but so this can
be done for anything around you that the
system can recognize basically any
objects around you you can see examples
of how that particular word is used one
fun sort of thing is that it's a lot
more engaging you don't have to like
look at a video or be the book or
something to learn English say as a
second language you can just go about
your day and learn about the words for
objects and how you pronounce it and and
some example users and so on we've even
gone a little bit further our hypothesis
is that if you learn in this very
situated way that basically you remember
the words a lot better than if you just
sort of are learning from a book or a
video and Christian just recently did
some tests where his hypothesis was that
if you use your whole body while you are
learning words related sort of to
certain gestures that basically you
would remember those words in that
second language that you're learning
better so he built a whole system that
recognizes what gesture you are
performing in a virtual world and it
tells you the word and you hear it as
well for everything every time you go
like this your your stab stab stab swing
and he did basically ran drink drink
pour pour and so on because this is the
way kids learn a language I mean you're
engaged in the action and your parents
or caregiver tells you sort of what what
things are called so he showed that
people who learn using this sort of
kinesthetic VR methods basically lose
less words so if you test them right
after they've studied they actually
perform about the same right after
they've basically studied all the words
in either the control or in the
kinesthetic learning or in a VR control
where you don't actually engage in the
activity yourself but you're in the
exactly same sort of setup so people who
learned actually in the kinesthetic the
number of words that they lose after
week is much smaller than the people in
a control both of the control groups and
we have a nice correlation that shows
that the more you times you engage in an
action and hear the words the better you
remember that words two weeks later and
the less likely that you forget that
word so showing that learning in this
full body way not just learning with
your head but learning with your whole
body involved is actually much more
effective than otherwise Mina can is
another student who's doing this the
same type of thing for math so she has a
whole system called math land using the
hololens that basically tells you or
teaches you about physics concepts in
your real world so you can bounce a
virtual ball off of the walls around you
and the objects around you and see what
speed and acceleration and all of that
is at different points in time you can
change gravity
and say like well what if I were on the
moon how would that ball bounce on the
moon and see I love that visualized she
recently built a multi-user version of
that system so that multiple hololens
users can basically have these sort of
puzzles math and physics puzzles that
eight together solve they can create
force fields and use all sorts of things
to make these Rube Goldberg like
machines and create puzzles for one
another or try to solve a puzzle that
somebody created using this mixed
reality type of setup and the name by
the way of the system math land is
inspired by Seymour Papert who said well
if you grow up in France you just
naturally learn French it's very easy
why don't we have something like math
land wouldn't it be great if we had a
math land that you could go to where you
just live there and you learn math just
like you learn French in France growing
up in France so the whole goal with her
system is to basically try to create
this kind of math land system note that
it doesn't always have to be an AI
system that sort of augments your
perception of reality in this system and
maybe I'll we started basically a remote
user of mence the visual field of a
person who needs help in this case with
the laser cutter so the remote expert
can actually make her hands available in
real time in the visual field of the
person who needs help showing him how to
like use his laser cutter which button
to push or what knob to turn how why to
sort of open something and so on and we
tested and the
paper is that CAI and showed that people
basically are able to solve things
remotely a lot better when they have
this augmented view where they can share
their gestures with one another in
real-time we are we do a lot of VR
learning work as well sort of this
immersive VR work PR learning work and
specifically we're working with
Professor John Belcher of the physics
department at MIT who teaches the
undergraduate required physics class
it's required for all MIT undergrads and
one of the things they learn about is
electrostatic so we made a whole VR
world where they can create charges and
fields and sort of see what happens
maybe some of you were there as
undergrads and still remember that class
but basically we did tests with MIT
undergrads and showed that the ones who
trained using this immersive system
again full body sort of all around the
physics simulation is all around you the
ones that train in the immersive system
do a lot better on the test the actual
tests that we have in this course they
do - isn't the number of the course so
they do a lot better than the ones that
trains on a 2d screen using the exact
same simulation so everything was kept
the same we have the people who trained
in VR and then the people who trained on
a flat screen but it's still a 3d
experiment basically or a 3d simulation
and the ones that experienced this in VR
did better on the tests memory is
another thing that using these types of
augmented cognition systems will be
totally transformed and I want to
highlight one
system that we built that I think is
very interesting
never mind is a system that uses the
principle of the memory palace to help a
person learn something the memory palace
is this really fascinating technique
that ancient Romans and Greeks already
had invented to try to memorize long
speeches and other information and it
basically consists of you sort of make a
virtual palace or it can be a whole path
somewhere in your minds and attach the
information that you have to remember to
sort of a path in this palace or a path
in this virtual space that you've
created and we actually make it easier
with our system for people to use this
technique by making use of augmented
reality so we didn't experiment where
people had to learn the Super Bowl
winners the consecutive Super Bowl
winners basically a very random set of
facts with not much logic to them and we
give them these material augmented
reality glasses and they show the
subsequent winners of the Super Bowl
superimposed on their experience of
reality when they follow a path that
they know very well that they're very
familiar with specifically in our case
going from the subway in Kendall Square
in Cambridge to the Media Lab building
and their office in the Media Lab and
the system basically shows you the
Panthers and the Jets and this and that
in sequence as you are going about going
from the tee to your office and it turns
out so that this is what that looks like
basically for the first and winners you
come out of the subway station and you
see someone with a lot of boxes for the
Packers going up the escalator and then
you see again another guy with a lot of
box
and then you come out of the subway and
you see a jet parked right there and you
come out of the subway you go to the
medical building and there is an Indian
for the Indian sitting on the stairs you
go through the medical building some of
you will know this path and know what I
mean but and you see two guys fighting
for the colds and then you see a cowboy
at the stairs to the media lab etc and
just experiencing this once you
basically remember the set of Super Bowl
winners for the rest of your life it's
really bizarre I can still do it so most
people just never forget because you tie
this factual information to an episodic
type of memory and your episodic memory
is very good but your factual memory is
actually much weaker so we had people in
a paper-based task and then in the
augmented reality task and this shows
you that right after people studied the
winners of the Super Bowl on paper or in
this augmented reality system they
perform the same but already like 24
hours later basically well they haven't
forgotten that
yeah the paper ones have already
forgotten more than 50% and then seven
days later they've forgotten even more
while the people that used the augmented
reality system keep they don't forget
any of the information that they have
learned basically so it really shows how
having this much more sort of immersive
interface where the your interface to
the digital world is more like real life
like is is basically highly effective
for things like memory and learning and
much more effective than other other
interfaces pay
/ flat-screens and so on that we've used
so far we work a lot of improving mood
and well-being as well one system for
example that we've been working on for
several years now is a system that uses
sense our experience of reality
obviously is not just visual and
auditory for people we have five senses
maybe six of you includes interception
and scent is actually an overlooked sort
of modality for interfaces not much
interesting work has been done but if
you look at the literature on scent in
psychology there's so much fascinating
information and and there's so much that
we HCI researchers could be doing to
make use of sense in interfaces for
example if you are studying say another
language or something else and you
present a certain sense while you're
studying and then you present that same
scent again when you are taking a test
say a couple days later you actually do
better on the test because this sense
having that this extra element of sense
helps you cue your memory and helps you
recall information and if you actually
present that same sense during sleep you
do even better so you can actually
present a scent during sleep and it
makes a person better on the test the
next day because they have in their
minds associated say vanilla or lavender
or whatever with learning that
particular say set of words in another
language sense can also be used to
influence mood to influence perception
of pain to influence attention and more
so Judith in my group has been building
scent interfaces like this one which it
takes into account or it can look at
EEG data about how focused you are as
well as electrodermal activity heart
rate temperature all sorts of things and
the system basically uses or via
bluetooth interacts with the phone and
the phone can control when the sense has
to be produced so it can be tied for
example two different sleep stages so
that they can present a certain sense at
the time that sleep researchers think
consolidation of memory into long-term
memory happens you can use it while
studying etc she now has a version with
multiple containers for multiple
situations
so that if you're behind the wheel and
you need you're a little too sleepy the
system can give you peppermint or citrus
or if you are a little bit anxious
because you're meeting with your advisor
it can give you a scent that calms you
down and so on so it knows what your
emotional status and can try to
influence your state based or using
sense judith also built another system
that gives you more insight into what it
means to be mindful and that helps you
teach you to be mindful so this system
as well uses the Meuse EEG system and
combines that with virtual reality and a
leap motion detector as well so that you
have superpowers in virtual reality when
you're focused like you can levitate but
then as soon as you think what's for
dinner or what's this problem set i have
to deal with you basically lose your
superpowers so you learn what it feels
like to be focused and you become better
at being focused given this feedback
basically by the system
one of my newer students have been
accepting a few students that have a
neuroscience background and one of them
Adam Horwitz has been systems for
interfacing during sleep again this is
sort of another area that HCI hasn't
really dealt with we only create
interfaces for awake conditions and we
even only create interfaces for
conscious use that people consciously
use where they have to put their
complete attention on the system there's
just so a lot that could be done
creating systems that we can use without
paying attention to them or that affect
us with others paying attention to them
and this particular system that Adam
builds actually interfaces during
certain sleep stages we started by
building a system that uses EEG as well
as other data temperature heartbeat eda
to do sleep staging to understand what
stage of sleep a person is in and there
is a particularly interesting sleep
stage between stage one and stage two
it's called hypnagogia and it's sort of
just when you're about to completely
fall asleep you're already sort of in a
very drowsy state but you're not
completely asleep yet and that is a very
interesting stage sort of where you can
basically do lucid dreaming and it's not
a totally crazy type of thing in fact a
lot of artists and scientists including
Fineman einstein dali they all used
lucid dreaming to be creative to help
them be creative they did it by
basically taking a latin nap with some
heavy objects in your hand and this
stage of sleep basically coincides with
atonia which when you lose muscle tone
so as soon as they would
through this stage the same metal ball
that they were holding or something else
would drop to the floor and that would
wake them up and then they would force
themselves to think about a particular
problem that they wanted to work on so
this system actually makes it easier so
it detects when you are entering when
you're going from sleep one stage to
sleep to and then we use at the moment a
conversational robots we also have a
version that just works on a phone
actually but here it's shown with Gebo
so as soon as you reach that stage Jibo
tells you to think about a particular
topic that you told it earlier you want
to be creative around so you can tell it
I want to think about this or that
problem and as soon as you enter that
stage it tells you to think about that
and then talks to you and record what
you say and we actually tested this it's
admittedly we only have eight people so
far that we collected data for but all
of the ones that were able to fall
asleep two of them were too wired to be
able to fall asleep but they basically
were able to use the system and they
dreamt about what we wanted them to
dream about so we gave them a word we
had two words that are both very sort of
neutral we had rabbit and fork and so
Gebo would tell them think about the
rabbits or think about a fork and these
are some of the quotes of our subjects
and I'll show you some quantitative data
as well but basically people sort of
report how basically their executive
functioning their logical self gets out
of the way and they can think more
broadly sort of about the topic in more
crazy ways basically because that stage
of sleep I mean your executive part of
your brain is basically the first parts
that
sort of turns off when you fall asleep
and so you can still kind of think about
a problem but it doesn't make that much
logical sense but that exactly is what
makes you makes it possible to come up
with more crazy ideas so we had a
control group and then a study group the
control group would just lie down with
their eyes closed and not fall asleep
basically but think about fork or rabbit
and then we had our condition group they
did basically fall asleep and the system
then talked with them about fork or
rabbit when we walk people up we had to
perform an alternative uses task which
is sort of a standard task that people
used to measure creativity and we also
had them basically dictate a story about
rabbit or fork and we then looked at
what they came up with in terms of
stories and also what alternative users
they came up with and the people in the
experimental condition basically showed
more creativity or better creativity
than the control group so these are just
some examples of some of the projects
that were working on but all of them
sort of fall in this category of going
beyond the interfaces that we use today
the smartphone's primarily that we use
today that are incredibly disruptive to
systems that really just change your
perception of reality and include
information in your perception of
reality or alter your perception of
reality these systems basically use make
use of implicit as well as explicit
stimuli again this implicit stimuli is
an area that I think is very much under
Ecch
explored in HCI there's been worked by
Hiro she she on ambient interfaces and
some work on comm technology and so on
but I think there's a lot more
opportunity for HCI systems to use
stimuli that affects a person's
cognition their attitudes and their
behavior
without a person even being aware that
it's happening and the systems that we
built make use of these implicit stimuli
they also make use of implicit inputs
information that can be sensed about a
user without a user having to enter
information about what it is they're
interested in or whether they're even
interested and focused on anything right
now or not and so on I think that these
this new idea this idea of augmentation
can really rescue our relationship with
smartphones if a device is always on
just in subtle ways changing your
reality it means that the use is less
disruptive because you don't have to
consciously sort of switch to use the
device by integrating sort of the
information in your perception of your
environment we avoid attention shifts
implicit interaction using multiple
modalities also reduces the demand for
conscious processing of inputs right now
everything your cell phone tells you
whether it's via voice or on the screen
you have to consciously sort of process
it and pay attention to it but there's
opportunities for just modifying a
person's reality without them needing to
be aware of it and embodied interfaces
that present information like that in
this very natural way just the way real
reality presents itself seem to be a lot
more effective for learning and for
helping people with memorization of
course we should be mindful
of possible dangers invasion of privacy
ones these systems sort of records
continuously everything happening around
us and inside of us that could be a huge
potential invasion of privacy if that
information is not kept private lack of
user understanding if a system changes
your reality you should be aware of the
ways in which it's doing that because
otherwise of course that can be problems
like that you become blind to real
reality or that you live in a bubble
world where you think everything is
beautiful because the system has maybe
edited out all the ugly parts of reality
around you these types of systems should
very much be under the control of the
user the use users should deliberately
choose how a system will impact their
perception and their behavior and last
we think a lot about dependency we don't
want people to become too dependent on
sort of a device that helps them with
things so we often try to design
solutions where the system itself makes
itself obsolete after a while and it may
help you with maybe forming a good
behavior or learning something but then
eventually you don't need a system
anymore because your behavior your
habits have changed or you have learned
what it is that you wanted to learn so
that's it thank you
yeah question
yes bellick he's very sick like like
memory augmentation this was like you
live in France then you'll learn French
but like if you look around like for
example one song you'll find a little
plus people have been doing it for
decades enough no word Cantonese right
so yeah yeah so like I wonder like like
do you think Lee is what the person just
once like bro
like is it continuing to continue to
work after the novelty of we don't
necessarily know but again like I
mentioned at the end I think a lot of
these we envision people using for a
while but then not needing to use it
anymore so maybe while you are learning
something you use sort of the the
augmentation that shows you the math
everywhere around your the Newtonian
physics everywhere around you but then
if you then feel like these you know
these concepts well enough you can turn
that off and it doesn't have to keep
overwhelming your sort of experience of
reality yeah yes continue they try to
come with this intervention from a
actually working right because there's
the millions of people who might not
have a college and there's challenges in
adoption and engagement what's your view
of like you know how
massif ID should we think about like you
know transforming things that people
already use everyday like a chair I mean
definitely there's you can sort of
augment a person's perception of reality
or you can change reality itself but I
think that typically the former is
cheaper is a cheaper approach actually
there is a lot of work of course on sort
of putting sensors and things in the
physical objects around us to to help us
with understanding certain phenomena or
learning certain phenomena but that I
personally think that those technologies
are much more expensive to make
accessible at a wide scale than but I'm
talking about here because basically 2.5
billion people have phones and I think
that this is where the where phones are
going basically so in another 10 or 15
years everybody will have heads-up
displays and with multiple sensors etc
and that will be what they use for all
their information needs and
communication needs as well so I think
that this is a in terms of strategy for
wide adoption and wide scaling that this
is a better approach than than trying to
create physical tangible smart things
sort of how or why these are the
technologies that people want to use in
a sense I think that we often invite
distraction upon ourselves that you know
if I have a device that could receive
messages for my friends that's what I'm
gonna want to do right yeah and you know
maybe the reason why I'm less distracted
when I'm reading a book is I can't so in
creating all these technologies that are
sort of even closer to our fingertips
that are on our body that are always
with
um is there a worry that we are just you
know we're going to circumvent the whole
you know pervasive ambient and and
really just dive into the same types of
distractions that we come to know and
love which is a richer access to
information it's possible yes maybe all
of the systems we built we're trying to
make them very minimal sort of and their
minimal interventions in your reality
but we don't know how these will be
rolled out or what people ultimately
will choose to do with them and it's
possible that they use them for maximum
distraction capability rather than sort
of really helping them with their
presence with their awareness of the the
here and the now and with whatever it is
that they're currently trying to get
better at or try trying to accomplish
we actually worked on autism
specifically maybe the closest that we
are to dealing with a particular
condition sort of is that several of my
students are working with Alzheimer's
patients and trying to do memory
augmentation for nots of the variety
that I showed here with the memory
palace but just helping a person with
like remembering who is the person that
is coming toward them what did they talk
about last time they had a conversation
and so on so those people really need
help sort of augmenting their memory so
that they can still sort of be social
and not socially awkward and can
maintain their relationships and remain
engaged in their social life so we are
using it in
in that context but I didn't include
that work here yet yep yes the hype to
augment us living just another
distraction iPhone three or four it's
just a smaller screen on your wrist so
I'm not at all excited about smart smart
watches other than for the sensing that
they can do that they can integrate
basically because they are in touch with
the body but so yeah we're not using
them at all because it's still you still
have to shift your attention I mean it's
a little bit faster than trying to dig
through my bag here to find my phone but
but it's still a complete distraction
and just the fact that it's so small
makes it so that you can even you even
have to pay more attention it seems our
attention for longer because not as many
bits can be shown necessarily on are not
tiny displayed and then can be when when
you're menteng your entire experience of
reality yeah unfortunately the current
systems the area where they're really
deficient is in inter interaction
basically so for a lot of these systems
we've had to create our own input
mechanisms gestural and others tracking
systems and so on because they're not at
all focused on inputs it's all about the
visual outputs yeah
well I think gestures are definitely
very interesting and I think not
necessarily special gestures that the
person needs to learn but there's so
many gestures that you perform that can
give a system information about your
intentions like if I pick up a book that
means I'm interested in it if I pick up
a book the fifth time the system should
know like what page I was at last time
around etc so that I think really doing
perception of the the users actions that
are not intended as special actions for
the machine but just their daily life
actions that we should go to we should
use that as a an input mechanism also
gaze and things like that yeah yes yeah
so the examples you showed how to be
placed on different areas of the body
depending on how is interacting with the
user or what kind of sensor that needed
I was wondering how you envisioned a
complete augmentation system to whether
it's like one system or like one item
that you can use or it involves yeah
right now we're doing many one of
experiments and systems although right
now we're trying to make a platform that
could be used for multiple experiments
memory decision-making learning etc
we're choosing to go with auditory
augmented reality just because that can
be done in a more acceptable form factor
we started doing all this work with the
hololens and of course you're not going
to walk around it's a whole dance in a
social context but we could you could
imagine walking around with bone
conduction headphones that just at the
right moment based on your context and
so on and information they can gather
about what you're doing and what your
intentions are can give you relevant
information in auditory way yeah
sorry I'm just wanted to measure like
cognitive augmentation being less
disruptive because for the example the
reasons that were you like that
interaction from with the projected yeah
well the way I'm imagining we didn't
necessarily test I mean this is really I
leave that it will make things less
disruptive but we actually haven't
tested disruption that would be very
interesting to do or to see like is
there less degradation of performance on
some tasks with these kinds of
interfaces so we haven't done that
that's that's more sort of the
motivation or the the hypothesis that we
believe will be the case I am going to
ask about at the end the use of the
information that's collected by all
these devices and the way that
information is presented to people
especially when it's in a very
personalized context and you know
especially now as you mentioned I think
there's a lot of concern that when you
have devices providing these kind of
personalized recommendations especially
if it's in this sense where you almost
don't realize or it's happening you know
I'm very subconsciously there can be a
lot of biases that I'm thinking of the
example of where someone took a book off
the shelf and they saw recommendations
for it yeah I mean depending on the
biases and in those recommendations I
mean it could affect what people study
and don't study read or don't read so
I'm just curious how do you think about
that problem when you're designing new
augmented reality devices and I mean
whatever thing needs to be done in that
space but more these kinds of devices
can become ubiquitous in origin so I
think that the problem isn't any
different from what is already happening
today everything you do online and even
to some extent of line
is already being collected and and is
taken into account in your social media
feeds and the ads that you see and all
of that all that information is already
being collected so we're collecting
similar but even more information but I
don't think that the problem is actually
the problem is already there and I think
already people aren't very aware of what
is going on so I think this this problem
is much bigger that people should be
more aware of what information is
collected about and what the system
assumes about them they should be able
to edit that and and remove parts of it
and decide who has access to it etc so
that's a much bigger problem that that
already very much affects all the
systems that we use today I think this
isn't you're talking about in the
existing system yes in ensuring that the
kind of information that's presented to
people is more biased and doesn't create
a bubble and if so do you have any ideas
about how that's even possible while
maintaining like personalization yeah I
think I mean that's a big question but I
think there are ways of doing that that
you can for example show people their
personal their personal recommendations
but still show them how that is very
different from everybody else around
them or how that situates them with
respect to other people and there's a
lot of good work like that that is
happening for example at a Media Lab
with Ethan Zuckerman or also that
brewery is doing a lot of sort of
visualizing of other groups that you
don't belong to and how do they see the
world and how is your view of the world
different from others or the same as
others and so on so I think people I'm
not against personalization but you
should be aware that it's going on and
aware that there's these very different
views of reality that other people may
see
[Applause]
you